so first of all rust is a programming
language it's been around for about 10
15 years or so now I could list a bunch
of facts about it but the more
interesting thing about it other than
the best things you need to know is much
more about the community and much more
about the other factors so I have found
what I've interacted with rust a very
welcoming Community which is someone
who's worked in the cloud native
Community something I really appreciate
when working with with people on
languages on our projects I sort of
really thought out and well and mature
ecosystem and honestly some of us help
whatever messages I've ever seen out of
a compiler which is really saying
something
um I had the Good Fortune to attend a
rust conference in London earlier this
year where I got my fantastic Ferris
plushie
um what really struck me about this
conference was how eager everyone was to
talk about the things they learned and
the things they knew and bring my
knowledge forward to other people
and I think that really reminded me of
kubernetes and the cloud native
ecosystem so I think we have a lot we
can do with each other so back on the
topic how does anything talk to
kubernetes to begin with
um well the animal fans cover your eyes
it is in fact actually Jason under the
hood
if you run qctl in verbose mode it will
tell you the HBS endpoint it's going to
hit and if you run it in really verbose
mode it will tell you the Json output it
got back to do this
um so all you really need in the
language to talk to kubernetes are
sockets
um and you can try this yourself so I'm
using a kind cluster here as an example
so I'm using certificate based
authentication but if you just pull your
certificates out of your cubeconfig and
there's five of them into a curl
invocation you will get some Json back
and you can use kubernetes perfectly
well this way if you really wanted to
um and you know Russ has very good
libraries for HTTP requests and TLS and
data handling but we can do a bit better
than that
so in in Rust a dependency is called a
crate and there is a cube crate which is
designed to handle interactions with a
kubernetes API in their own words from a
documentation they're built in the style
of client go and controller runtime and
Cube Builder from a go ecosystem I
should stress I'm not a developer of a
cubecrate I'm just a great admirer of
their work
um so I'm going to show you some code I
do not have time to explain how rust
Works in its syntax so I'm just going to
walk you through the important bit
you'll have to trust me
so what we're going to do in this code
snippet is we are going to list some
pods from the kubernetes API in the
default namespace so first of all we're
going to create a client configuration
we're going to ask it to try the default
this will go and look for a cubeconfig
on disk and the various other default
ways of accessing kubernetes
um we're going to do this async using
async await in Rust because it does file
IO and then that question mark at the
end is error handling don't worry about
it is error handling
um once we've got on that config we're
going to create an API for pods so this
is typed on a pod that's what those
angle brackets are go developers
um we are going to tell it to look in
the default namespace and we're going to
pass in the client configuration that we
created in the last line once we've
created this we're just going to do a
simple list operation because a normal
Cube CTL get kind of thing actually
there's a list under the hood
um we're going to default listening
parameters and again we're going to do
the async and the error handling once
we've got that list
um we're going to get it into an
iterator we're going to iterate over all
the pods we get back and we're going to
grab the metadata.name so we're going to
get the name of a pod
um in kubernetes all objects names are
optional so we're going to tell it what
to do there is no name which is we're
just going to set it to the empty string
and then we're going to collect it up
and dump this out into standard out and
if you run this it will just give you
the list of name pod I only had one pod
in my my default namespace called Debian
it's a pretty simple example so the
cubecrate itself can do a lot more than
that it has full support for all the
verbs you'd expect it's got crd support
it does a whole bunch of stuff to check
out the documentation
um so what does this mean for the
ecosystem well
um when you're working with a new
project and you're starting from scratch
language choice is one of the most
impactful early decisions that you can
make and rust will not be appropriate
for every project I'm not trying to
suggest it will be but if you are
thinking of looking at rust for your
project for whatever reason
don't be afraid of using it to talk to
kubernetes
thank you
[Applause]